so hi
um and i'm asia and i have a question
for you
can you read the title of this lecture
can you
and how about now isn't it a little bit
more difficult
so this is how i see it it's blurry
and for me it's significantly harder to
read this text
so hi again i'm asean
i have a
bachelor's degree in computational
biology and a master's in computer
science i work as an algorithm team lead
and a developer at evinst which is a
small
startup based in tel aviv israel
and in my free time i like traveling and
hiking and my love for traveling led me
all the way to antarctica a few years
ago
but until this point i haven't explained
to you why i see blurry and in order to
understand it we need to go back in time
to the moment i was born because right
after i was born i didn't respond to
light stimulations at all
and the doctors suggested i might be
blind
after a while it was discovered that i'm
not blind but
i am visually impaired due to albinism
so what is albinism albinism is an
inherited genetic condition that
manifests itself in a lack of the
pigment melanin
and melanin plays a crucial part in the
development of the eye in the embryonic
stage and so people with albinism tend
to have
various visual
problems such as lazy eyes crossed eyes
and many more and in those embarrassing
childhood pictures of mine you can see
some of those
problems that i have until this day
so what does it mean to me
to be an albino
in my everyday life and to be visually
impaired it means that i struggle to
read small text in print
and i often struggle to read
text from the blackboard in the lecture
hall or even to read my own lecture
notes when i speak in public
when i work on the computer
i usually enlarge all the fonts
of the programs that i am using and i
often struggle to find the font
enlargement option in the programs that
i'm using
actually
just a few weeks ago i discovered how to
do that on pycharm like easily
and so
it's it's really a struggle
and when i work with data
it's usually a
visual data i work on computer vision
problems and often i struggle to to make
the right decisions for my research and
i tend to rely more on statistics and on
the opinions of people around me to make
the right choices uh for my research and
my projects
however my story is not unique
um as of to 2015 there were over
217 million people who were
visually impaired
in a moderate to severe level
and over a
36 million people
were blind
in total over 250 million people over
the world
are blind all those are a visual
impaired sorry and all those people um
use technology just like anyone else and
there are various tools that help them
to use technology such as
screen readers and magnifying glass
software and many more however websites
and mobile apps need to be built in a
specific way
in order for those assistive
technologies to help those people get
the full information in a
intuitive and easy way
all those websites and mobile apps need
to be built in an accessible way
so events the company i work at focuses
on digital accessibility at evinst we
believe that accessibility is the
responsibility of the developers and so
we build
tools and
we help
companies incorporate accessibility into
their
development process and so we help
companies all over the world
make their
websites and mobile apps
more accessible
to people who are visually impaired and
to people with other disabilities
so
until this point i explained to you what
it means for me to be visually impaired
and i hope that i convinced you that
accessibility is an important subject
let's now discuss a specific
area and specific struggle that people
who are visually impaired
might
tackle
and
we'll see how i tried to solve this
problem and the solution i came up with
in the end
so here we have two buttons
and on the top we have a button that is
a light blue with white text over it and
in the
lower part we have a button that is a
dark blue with a white text over it
and so those buttons are identical in
everything
except for the background color of the
button
and
the
color contrast
between the
light blue
background and the white text is not
high enough
and so people who are visually impaired
might not be able to read
this
the text on this button and if the uh
this button exists in a crucial part in
flow in the website for example if it's
a button that
is required somebody is required to
press in case they they want to book a
flight or a hotel this means that this
website won't be accessible
to the people who are
who have a low vision
and
and so that might be a problem
but how do we know that um
some color combination of the background
and
the foreground text
is not accessible
in order to understand it we need to um
to learn some
photometric um terms
um so first the first term is luminance
so luminance
expresses the
the amount of light that is uh um
perceived by the person um and it it is
emitted from the surface
um and if we normalize this
[Music]
luminance between 0 and
and 1 we have relative luminance
and this term can be
used in order to calculate something
that we call a color contrast ratio
and
basically we take two colors the
dark
darker color and the light lighter color
we calculate relative luminance for each
of those colors
and we can get
the color contrast ratio between those
colors
and
and once we have this
color contrast ratio
and we we can use a standard
that exactly specifies what should be
the color contrast ratio for two colors
in order for them to be
accessible and visible to
people who are visually impaired and so
this
is a standard simple mathematical
equation
and basically there are many tools
online that help
designers and web developers
calculate the color contrast ratio
between
the colors that they are using on their
websites and so this is actually a
solved problem once you want to
have some text overlaid on some constant
background and
everyone can check
those two color combinations
if
it passes the
the criteria that is specified by the
standard
this means that
this color combination is accessible and
everything is good but what happens if
attacks is overlaid on top of a complex
background
such as an image or a gradient in this
case
the text can just blend into the
background and it won't be accessible or
readable to people with
low vision
and
what people who
work as
accessibility
experts do in this case it just sample
pixels around
the
text and calculate the color contrast
ratio that i explained earlier
and so um
after doing that they can assess if the
text is accessible or not
and however there is no tool that is
actually
automatic and does that for them and it
actually it's actually a task that is uh
it takes a lot of time is manual and
subjective
and and this was my goal actually
i wanted to develop an algorithm that
solves
the problem of
classifying tech text overlaid on a
complex background into a readable
or non-readable text
okay
so
um when i started this task i actually
had some uh
poc code that was developed earlier
and
when i started working on it i just
tried to use the code that i had
and this poc code that i had
relied heavily on ocr technology ocr is
basically
extracting text out of
images
and so this poc code what it did it
planted text into images
and after that
run an
ocr
engine called tesseract
and
the ocr engine extracted the text out of
the image and it and it was compared to
the
text inserted into
the image if they were identical
everything is good
and the text was classified as a
readable
however if they weren't
um
identical the text was classified as
non-readable
okay sounds great right
um so i wanted to check this
this
code how it works on real data the
problem was i didn't have any data
and i had to collect it manually
and fortunately i knew some
javascript and um i built a scraper that
um
i collected
images of text from the internet
and so i had pairs of texts and images
of of this text outlooks on websites and
after that i applied
the ocr engine that
was in the poc code specifically
tesseract and i wanted to see what are
the results and to what i'm getting
so this is an example of a text that is
very clear to us
however tesseract returned
just blank
weird right
here is another example
it's a
another image of a text that is very
clear very readable and again
tesseract returns just gibberish what is
going on
so
um i try to understand what tesseract is
doing and how it's working and i came to
a few conclusions so first tesseract is
an ocr engine that is meant
for documents for extracting text out of
documents how documents look
basically it's black text over white
paper
and
it's slightly different from the images
that i had
um
another thing that is nice about esserak
it's that it has a python wrapper a
really nice python
library that is really easy to use and
it's a great tool for prototyping
it supports many languages it's another
great advantage of
tesseract
and it's actually easy to train
for new languages or new characters
however the cons that i saw from for my
task were that tesseract works on images
that have a high
quality over 300 dpis whereas the data
that i collected was
72 dpis which was much less
in order to improve um
the results of tesseract um
anyone can do a certain image processing
operations such as
turning images into black and white
or
or
reducing noise
and
those
operations really can improve the
results of tesseract however i was
afraid that for my task they might harm
the classification so i decided not to
do it
another thing that tesseract is
slightly poor at
is that um it returns
not that good results on small
characters in small text
and
it also sometimes fails on special
characters such as
currency signs
so until this point uh basically i tried
to use a tesseract ocr engine on the
data that i collected
um
and i found out that it's not the right
tool for me however i didn't give up
on the possibility of using an ocr
engine
on my data and i started searching
online for other ocr engines
luckily i came across
a post by jan lee kuhn who is uh one of
the godfathers of deep learning and head
of
a aiat meta and jan le kun recommends in
his post um
an ocr engine called easy ocr um and
this is a
tool that is based on pytorch and uses
um
modern deep learning algorithms and so i
decided that if jan le [ __ ] recommends
something i should definitely try it
um so let's see how easy ocr works
so
first it gets an input image then it
applies pre-processing on it
next stage uh it detects
text out of uh
of of the image using a model called
craft please remember in the name we'll
return to it later
and after that it performs um
a text recognition and so it turns um
the
characters or the text detected earlier
into a sequence of characters and in the
last end uh in last part it uh
basically decodes their sequence of
characters into a meaningful text
so
each part of this process is actually um
can be
replaced by a different model it's a
very modular
system
and it's
let's see how it works
on the examples that we saw earlier so
here we see that easy ocr does a better
job on those examples
but let's see
two more examples
here we see that easy ocr makes mistakes
on
some of the characters
and such as
the s sign it replaces it with the
dollar sign or
it
doesn't recognize well the percentage
sign
and
so let's see
what
i found out about easy ocr so the first
thing is that easy ocr is um
meant for detecting
text in the wild so um
tesseract works best is meant for
detecting text on documents while easy
ocr detects text in the world which
means that it recognizes text in
natural scenes such as street signs for
example
it's based on pie torch which i
personally think is a pro
but not everyone would agree with me
it's a really modular system each uh
part of it can be replaced by a
different model
and
as its name suggests it's easy to use
and there is a really nice python
package for that
the concept i saw is that first
it
doesn't work that well on black and
white images
which
were a tesseract performs well
and
it makes mistakes on special characters
such as the percentage signs and
currency signs
so
until this point basically i tried
two ocr engines in order to solve
my problem of
classifying text overlaid on top of an
image into a readable or not readable
text and
i came to the conclusion
that
neither of these
systems works for me
and
i
i try to think how i can combine them or
maybe trying a different ocr engine but
i came to the conclusion that um
the the those system might be too
complex and it might be hard to maintain
and debug
and so
at this time stage i decided to
recalculate my route
and to try a different perspective
so
basically the perspective i tried so far
it was trying to
use a poc
code and make it work
and
until this point i learned a lot of
things and i decided to try my own a
build my own system my own code based on
the things that i learned so far
and so
as part of the this
perspective change i decided to use
three basic principles um
in my
development stage and the first one is
splitting
big problems into
smaller problems the second one is using
only the relevant existing parts and not
using big system
just
because it's there
and the third one is finding the right
balance in my data set
to make
the best out of my model
and let's go out
over each one of those principles
so the first principle is really simple
is splitting a big problem into smaller
problems
um so we have here a text
it's written here and feel good
and by looking at this text we can see
that um the text is not very clear but
it's hard to quantify
however if we go over each one of those
characters for example
the e on the right and the o on the left
we can see easily that the e is readable
and the o is not
and so if we go over each one of those
characters we can calculate the
the ratio of the bad characters and the
ones that are not clear and not readable
out of the
entire text
and
according to a predefined threshold for
example if we decide that um
only
texts that have
a 0.8 um
good
contrast ratio out of everything and
then the text is a is readable in this
case this text won't pass and it would
fail our
our
condition
so
the next principle is using only the
relevant existing parts for
my problem until this point i used ocr
engines as black boxes
and
when they failed
for example when tesseract returned
gibberish it was really hard for me to
debug and to understand what is going on
um
and instead of just using a big black
box i decided to use only a small part
out of um
out of the systems that i tried i
decided to use the craft model which is
meant for um
detecting text
and so i
used craft which is
a model that basically
calculates for each
pixel in the image the probability of
this pixel to be in a center of
of a character
and based on this probability
we can build a heat map where the high
probability and
would be the
area where
that are red and in the areas that we
have lower probability the colors would
be blue
and so we can uh
extract out of
the image uh the bounding boxes of uh of
the characters and and we can have uh
small
images of the characters in the text
and after that the next stage is
basically classifying all those
of those characters into
readable or not readable
characters
and this leads me to the third principle
which is finding the right balance in
the data set
basically i model my
this
problem of
classifying characters into readable or
not readable characters as a binary
classification problem
however it's not actually a binary as we
have some scale
where in one hand we have characters
that are very
clear and readable and on the other hand
we have characters that
are not
um and this scale is actually very
subjective and
every person has their own scale and
people with
low vision might have a different scale
at all
so
another thing that affects
the problem when trying to label this
data
is that uh we sometimes have
an effect that is called anti-aliasing
so what is anti-aliasing is basically a
method of rendering um rendering on a
screen and when we talk about
fonts and characters basically it does
some smoothing effects on the characters
and however when the characters and the
fonts are
very thin it means that the
color of the text blends into the
background and so it makes
things
look
much
worse than
they are actually
and
and so uh when i tried
um using the label data that i had
that was manually labeled
i had a bunch of
subjective labels basically and um
and the model that i trained on this
data didn't perform that well
um and
so i decided to enrich the data set that
i had with a label that were objective
that were labeled based on the standard
that defines exactly what is a
readable
character and what is not and
i performed a series of experiments
where i trialled different balances
between those two groups until i had a
model that performed well and
and did well on
the entire set
so how does the entire solution work
so first uh it gets an input image and a
text
and then it runs craft in order to
extract characters
uh from the text
each of those characters is
labeled um and classified into a
readable or not readable character and
after that um
the bad contrast ratio
character
a is
computed
and in the end based on the threshold we
classify the entire text
and we assess if it's accessible or not
so until this point
i explained to you how i try to use
ocr architectures in order to understand
if a text that is incorporated in an
image is accessible or not i tried
different
ocr architectures specifically
tesseract and easy ocr and i came to a
conclusion that none of them them is
good enough for my task
and after uh
much thought i uh reframed the problem
and
i
developed my own system
and
and this actually led to a breakthrough
and to a system that
manages to classify
texts
well
and
and now it's a part of our
project product
basically um events has a product
that is meant for scanning
big websites of our clients
and um
one of the things that we scan for are
texts that are
and not
not accessible since they are overlaid
on a complex background
and
when i ran the system over
over many websites i found out that
this is actually a problem that is
um
more relevant for specific
areas such as travel and art and design
are news websites
and things that are more
visual
and
here are some examples of a text that
were detected as and not non-readable
um and you can see here that um those
texts are actually not very clear not
only to people
with low vision
but
also to two people
with a
good vision
and
so this leads me to
my
last point
and
in the beginning of the lecture i told
you that over 250 million people over
the world
i are visually impaired
solutions such as the one that i
presented today
um can help them in their everyday life
i
ask you to think about how you can
incorporate accessibility into your
everyday life
either in how you write your code or how
how you build your presentations or how
you
create plots
and let's together make the world more
inclusive for people uh
with a visual vision impairment and to
people
with disabilities thank you
thank asia
[Music]
is there any question
okay
thanks uh that was a really great talk
um
do you have any advice for uh how to
make things more accessible for people
who are colorblind um in in particular
in data science heat type
presentations
yeah so so actually um
what i talked about the
the standard is also
meant for
not only for people who are who have low
vision but also people with color
blindness so it actually incorporates
people with color blindness but
basically what i can say is that
there are
certain color combinations that just
don't work everybody knows about like
green and
red
um
so basically don't use them but there
are
more color combination that are not good
enough so basically the tools that i
presented and can be used for that as
well like basically
colors that have
high contrast ratio color contours ratio
would work
and another thing that i can
suggest is
not rely only on color
for a
conveying information but add something
else like text or
some kind of effect that
makes thing more clear for people that
don't recognize color that well
got a question
then
i have a question
hi thank you for your presentation i was
wondering uh
what are the main challenges faced by
visually impaired people who are abroad
i'm sorry i didn't hear
what are the challenges faced
by visually impaired people browsing the
web
today
oh there are so many
many
challenges
i
can't like start for it so the colors of
course
but
there are also
websites that are just like you know
too much
like too much color too much everything
everything is popping
um
yeah so
i
always look on websites and i just
sometimes think what people were
thinking because
you know
sometimes they are designers and it
looks good but when you try to to look
for the information you need you can't
so
basically that
i wanted to ask you a question you said
uh about easy ocr that you thought that
by torch is an advantage
why why do you think i know by torch is
better than other frameworks
what's your experience um
yeah so
i have experience with the tensorflow
and pytorch and basically everything in
pytorch is easier and simpler so
so i think that's that's
a better tool
it's more about usability less about
models or pre-trained things i think
that you can do like everything
in both
but uh
when when you want to to do something
just that works simply and get things
done then the poetry is better in my
opinion
any other question yeah
thank you for your good presentation and
i have a question do you think it's
possible to do a further step that
recommend a
specific font color
for
colorful background
uh
well
franz is
it's actually like a
full area right that there are so many
phones
and there are people that are just
trying to understand which fonts are uh
accessible and which are not so i can't
like tell you which font you should use
but
generally
there are fonts that
are better
and you should like
try and search what works out for you i
really invested time in like picking the
right fonts and the right colors for my
presentation
it took time i for example used
quicksand which is i think it's okay
but
yeah
then this is i think we ran out of time
thanks a lot azia again for your talk
[Applause]